In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for October 6th, on which we commemorate, our Holy Father
Innocent, Metropolitan of Moscow, Enlightener of the Alliads, and Apostle to America.
Enlightenessent Ivan John Evsevich Popov Venyaminov was born on August 26th in the year 1797
into the family of a church server in the village of Anginskoye, Verkolensk district,
Irkutsk province in Russia.
His father died when John was 6.
In 1807, John entered the Irkutsk Theological Seminary.
In 1817, he married, and on May 18th, 1817, he was ordained deacon of the Church of the
Annunciation in Irkutsk.
He completed his studies in 1818.
He was appointed a teacher in a parish school, and on May 18th, in the year 1821, he was
ordained priest to serve in the Church of the Annunciation.
At the beginning of 1823, Bishop Michael of Irkutsk received instructions to send a priest
to the island of Unalaska in the Allusian Islands of Alaska.
After John Venyaminov volunteered to go, and on May 7th, 1823, he departed from Irkutsk,
accompanied by his aging mother, his wife, his infant son Innocent, and his brother, Stefan.
After a difficult one-year journey, they arrived at Unalaska on July 29th in the year 1824.
After John and his family built and moved into an earthen hut, he undertook the construction
of Holy Ascension Church on the island and set about studying the local languages and dialects.
He trained some of his parishioners in construction techniques, and with them undertook the construction
of a church which was finished the following July.
After John's parish included the islands of Unalaska and the neighboring Fox Islands
and Pribylov Islands, whose inhabitants had been converted to Christianity before his arrival,
but retained many of their pagan ways and customs.
Father John often traveled between the islands in a canoe, battling the stormy Gulf of Alaska.
This travels over the islands greatly enhanced Father John Venyaminov's familiarity with
the local dialects.
In a short time he mastered six of the dialects.
He devised an alphabet of Cyrillic letters for the most widespread dialect, the Unagan dialect
of Alliote, and in 1828 translated the Holy Gospel of St. Matthew and other church materials
into that dialect which were eventually published in 1840 with the blessing of the Holy Synod
of the Russian Orthodox Church.
In the year 1829 he journeyed to the Bearing Seacost of the Alaskan mainland.
In 1836 his travels even extended to the south, to the Ross Colony, north of San Francisco,
and to the Spanish missions of Northern California.
At Ross Colony he conducted services at its small wooden chapel.
In 1834 Father John was transferred to Sitka Island to the town of Novo Arcanheltsk.
Later called Sitka and studied their language and customs.
His studies there produced the scholarly works, notes on the Kuluskan and Kodiac tongues,
and other dialects of the Russo-American territories with a Russian Kuluskan glossary.
In 1838 Father John journeyed to St. Petersburg and Moscow, Russia and Kiev, Ukraine, to report
on his activities and request an expansion of the church's activities in Russian America.
While he was there he received notice that his wife had died.
He requested permission to return to Sitka.
Instead it was suggested that he take vows as a monk.
Father John at first ignored these suggestions, but on November 29th in the year 1840 made his
vows.
He chose the name Innocent, in honor of Bishop Innocent of Irkutsk.
The Apostle to the Alliutes on December 15th in the year 1840 Archimandrite Innocent
Venyaminov was consecrated Bishop of Kamchatka and Kudil Islands in Russia and the Alliushin
Islands in Russian America.
His sea was located in Novo Arcanheltsk which he returned to in September 1841.
He spent the next nine years in the administration of his sea as well as on several long missionary
journeys to its remote areas.
On April 21st in the year 1850 Bishop Innocent was elevated to Archbishop.
In 1852 the Yakut area was admitted to the Kamchatka diocese and in September of 1853 Archbishop
Innocent took up permanent residence in the town of Yakutsk.
Innocent took frequent trips throughout his enlarged diocese.
He devoted much energy to the translation of the scriptures and service books into the
Yakut Sakha language.
In April of 1865 Archbishop Innocent was appointed a member of the Holy Governing Synod of the
Church.
On November 19th in the year 1867 he was appointed the Metropolitan of Moscow, replacing his friend
and mentor Filaret, who had died.
While there he undertook revisions of many church texts that contained errors, raised funds
to improve the living conditions of priests and established a retirement home for priests.
Innocent died on March 31st in the year 1879.
He was buried on April 5th in the year 1879 at Troice Sergeva Lavra.
On October 6th in the year 1977 the Church of Russia acting on the official request of the
Orthodox Church in America proclaimed Innocent Assaint.
This feast day is celebrated twice a year on October 6th and on March 31st.
In 1994 during excavations on the grounds near the Holy Ghost Church at the Troice Sergeva
Lavra, St. Innocent's relics were discovered and are now venerated by the faithful both
in Russia and in America.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.